entrepreneurship is hard and lonely if
you look at the current state of social
media you would think that 98% of the
time in entrepreneurship it's sunny and
rosy and fun when in reality it's double
burst the reality is most people spend a
lot of their times day in and day out in
dark clouds not sunshine when you own
your own business everything is your own
fault you are basically in the business
of putting out negative fires
disproportionally our time is spent in
navigating or anticipating dark clouds
it's not glamorous it's not getting the
accolades of selfies and and being there
it's not the big time meetings with the
biggest companies in the world
it's just hardcore dirt and I think that
anybody that doesn't realize that is not
building an actually successful business
they're living in a fake environment or
they're naive and they don't realize
it's coming the percentage of successful
entrepreneurs ones that can make a
living and live their lives on their own
back not in a company structure is quite
low we are in the firefighter business a
person who lives their life every day of
anxiety of knowing they are the last
line of defense not glamorous it's hard
[Music]
the sunshine subjective right that's why
these people become losers who come in
that lake I'm going to complex con I got
my new case Swiss sneaker dropping and
I'm doing a talk with Karen civil and
drama and a couple others so just roll
through LA and then I'm taking the
red-eye home
hello mmm I'll see you a little bit
hey what up thank you so much everybody
wanted to be an astronaut one day like
it every kid that I'm looking at these
good-looking kids they all wanted to be
astronauts and pilots in 1957 because
that what do they want to be now
entrepreneurs I mean this is my moment
and by the way it'll be fun and a nine
years the world will melt
everybody will not be an entrepreneur
anymore it won't be cool they'll blame
entrepreneurship for the melt and I'll
still be an entrepreneur because that's
what I've always been that's what I am
now and that's what I'll be to the last
breath turn that James ya doing I like
the green makes me feel very jet linear
je2 that's good let's go baby
good my dude I love that dude thank you
do not make you for like three years
yep I'm messing with Atlanta where I
connect to him was through your DM
advice you've got to be fulfilled with
your process not what you're trying to
get out of your process if you do
something trying to get something out of
your process you will always lose
because you're gonna be impatient you're
like why don't I have a fat watch or a
million followers yet because that's the
only reason you're doing it when you do
something for the second thing not the
thing you're always going to see my
doing on how are you man it was complete
pleasure for me much love yeah man keep
doing your thing yo let me help
you'll hit me up with that I think she
says I can really really help give me
with that seriously help me out my house
shoot all right okay no fear wait to see
my dude YouTube
[Music]
a lot of people are making 86 thousand
dollars a year at a job they hate
imagine making seventy-nine thousand a
year selling something you love that
doesn't mean that you're gonna own
Ferraris and sixteen homes but happiness
needs to be the edge Karina's 6:00 p.m.
I'll be downstairs I'm down real
pleasure you're there
awesome sorry not sorry
little got it little keys for those too
heavy heavy I love those two guys good
I'm really
I like how you navigate through
adversity and I like how you're like get
to keep building building building they
can't stop us Gary we didn't come this
far to quit but that's the truth
[Music]
one shooter man wants to do people die
in the street yeah don't catch him
brother step knowledge to him so that he
can think for themselves but don't hug
him I see a nurse in sick and asking
we'd like to start blasting sick away
and we bout to start taking we occupy
the spot lead em off
[Music]
by just recognizing that it's the place
of ultimate strength by like just really
talking to yourself every day I'm not
over judging yourself by realizing that
that gives you the biggest chance to
happiness the reason I didn't care being
29 in my dad's liquor store packing
boxes not having any money was cuz I
didn't care what anybody thought about
I practiced practiced and practiced it
he understand all right guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
shut up
[Music]
the next step is whatever is on my mind
at that moment that makes me happy
[Music]
complex con is a physical manifestation
of the current state of the culture like
this is this is the current version of
the baseball card shows I did when I was
14 the flipping mentality people want to
kill each other just to get that thing
to make a couple bucks or to get that
fresh stuff it's just it's the pulse of
the reality of the youth you know
welcome what's your name nice to meet
you bro you look real fresh browsing
yeah man you having a good time
you like wu-tang clan
the entitlement yeah amazing you know
what to do I got 24/7 thank you
I got some good time let's go big family
thank you both for the care there you
have it complex calm we came through
hard and we did it saw the culture
tasted it brought as much value as I
could can loved it we loved your complex
calm we'll see you next year if you're a
purebred entrepreneur you love the dark
clouds you understand that the fake
entrepreneurship hero we live through
loves the sunshine when it's good and
happy and easy but if it's in your DNA
if you actually are not so anyone you
know exactly why the upcoming year of
dark clouds is going to be very
important because at the end of the day
this is a game based on merit and if you
don't know how to navigate those storms
you can't be in all time on floor I love
the dark clouds because they're part of
the process
you